I'm Sarah Brown I've just come from the
South Asia children's session
representing the Global Business
Coalition for education and also talking
about the white ribbon alliances work in
maternal health and campaigning I was
putting the case there for advocacy and
how much we need to niche together both
the health world and the education
worlds now and really bring a level
playing field together for the private
sector government and nonprofits working
together I think so many amazing
organizations are doing so much across
India and across the whole of South Asia
but we really need to get the maximum
push we can now by working together in a
much clearer and coherent way